I actually want to start out with just
thanking you so much all for being here
I really appreciate your time I know
that little uh show there did not show
it but I really do I really appreciate
this opportunity to talk to you so
um my name is Andrew Holtz and the name
of my presentation is oops I'm a manager
and I'd like to start off by talking a
little about who I am to set that
context um so who I am now is I'm at pit
um I am a engineering manager there on
the open source group and I get to spend
my time supporting the shiny team and
the Cordo team mlops team MLV team
working with amazing people but if we
roll back the clock a little uh say
about 245 years ago I was a system
engineer at Bell labs and I was a coding
some C++ doing some mapping stuff having
a good time writing lots of requirements
documents that were big then
um working on a big Operational Support
system um and then a different group
within my uh Department kind of bun out
and took over some products and they
recruited me to join them so there I am
you know Young starting off my career
with like a dozen or so experienced Bell
Labs grizzled veterans we got 10 years
15 years 25 years in the trenches we're
now starting this new Venture and
they're looking for someone to help
organize looking to help someone set
goal deal with the little customer stuff
pretty much everyone else in that line
took a big step back and I was kind of
standing forward and I said oh well I
have my computer science and psychology
double major yeah let's go let's give it
a shot so I sort of started like really
early on into this management role so
that's so um this today is me having had
this great experience getting into it
early in this technical managerial path
um and I've had so many opportunities
through it and I kind of want to share
it and I want to share it through one
particular exercise around one-on ones
that I think is a great way to test out
if maybe this is a path for you and
that's the goal here today
so um why one-on ones why do I want to
talk about one-on-one so much well
one-on ones in my experience create
trust like you're talking to that other
person it's individual you're talking
about what matters it's in a very
specific context that builds up trust
over time and that's the connection
connective tissue that make really great
teams work if there's a lot of trust
among the team you're going to have a
team that's really executing at a high
level and I'll tell you being part of a
team that's executing at a high level is
like the best kind of way to work and a
lot a lot of fun so why one-on ones
though specifically there's a lot of
leadership things you could talk about
to help the team well the fact of the
matter is one-on ones if you're doing
them right are scheduled
regularly they're two people so there's
a room for both of them and in fact a
need for both of them to actively
participate and that because it's
repeated and because it's a shared
responsibility both people need to do
their part of it no matter what role
you're in in an organization one-on ones
give you the opportunity to practice
your leadership skills so it's really
good to focus in on it's regular so it
happens and you can say hey how did that
one go learn over time and you can
exercise leadership muscles again from
pretty much any position uh in in in a
company or in an organization and then
lastly again one-on ones are just really
important some conversations aren't
going to happen anywhere else that are
so important about career growth and
opportunities and things like that you
got to have one-on ones to have those
and then there's also some other topics
that maybe aren't so obvious that are
important so I'd like to talk just a
little bit more about that so I'm not a
neurologist no very little about about
the brain but I did take my site classes
and so to set this up um
maybe you've been in a meeting where
someone was talking about something and
someone else kind of like overreacted
maybe didn't just overreact a little but
seemed to kind of freak out over
something relatively innocuous well we
have some brain chemistry going on there
the prefrontal cortex is the part of
your brain that's responsible for like
logic and rationality and deep work and
all this great stuff we also have
amigdalas that were for you know really
important to human surviving and all
these things along those years well what
is the amigdala do it's scanning the
environment it's scanning the
environment looking for danger and if
danger comes up it tells you know your
prefrontal cortex hey quiet down we
don't have any time for your crap we
need to fight or flight well the fact of
the matter is group meetings are complex
environments and so you have this risk
of actually having that amydala trigger
over something maybe that didn't seem
like it deserved it but it triggers it
shuts down rationality you get that
overreaction and it can really cause a
lot of damage that you you stay with for
that can stay with a team um for a long
time so we have these really important
topics not just about career growth but
about other things that are best covered
in a one-on-one so hopefully I've made
the case that uh one-on-ones are pretty
important again we got better
one-on-ones we're building trust between
team members um that results in stronger
teams over time what I'd like to do is
run through three different flavors
there's some overlap here you may have a
different role in different ones it's
okay there's a little bit of a lesson
hopefully from any of them we're going
to talk about a goal for each one and
then we're going to uh talk about a
specific tactic cuz in my experience if
you have a habit if you can build it in
you can get better at something and
improve and if you don't have a simple
thing to do to repeat it's hard to kind
of keep it front of mind and keep
getting better at it so um first type
most common type probably the most
important one probably applies to pretty
much when everyone here we have a team
lead and a team member we're trying to
build trust we know that that's one of
the goals I've already made the case for
that that's just so important to a team
operating
um and then we have the idea of
establishing goals and by establishing
goals I mean what's the group goals you
want to make sure we're on the same page
and understanding of that we also have
individual goals and really what we want
is align alignment between them so a
really good career conversation again
one of those foundational one-on-one
ideas is getting aligned of hey I'm
really interested in learning this thing
and hey the team has a gap in that let's
put them together that's a great career
conversation that's going to set both
the team and the individual up to be
successful within it um giving feedback
obviously one-on ones are a really
important place to do that and I mean
both ways giving feedback isn't just
team lead to team manager or or yeah it
is both team lead uh to to the team
member and back uh vice versa so one of
the things that I learned over time um
or I got was taught let's say about
management uh and doing one-on ones is
well if you have to give someone
feedback you feed them a crap sandwich
um so we have a piece of bread I guess
that's the good part and then we have
the harsh criticism maybe in the middle
so I guess that's the crap and then
another piece of bread on the other end
to to make a sandwich of it um my
experience that that's fine you
definitely want a mix of good and bad
things you want to predominate with good
as much as you can focus on positives
where you can not avoiding the important
feedback when it comes up um but in my
experience it's much better to start
with a uh here's a specific observation
this is something that happened in as
factual terms as I can and then ask
questions about it don't assume you know
that everything's going on um that is a
form of feedback hey here's this
Behavior maybe it had some consequences
maybe it wasn't ideal but like let's
talk about it I want to understand it
better I want to see where you're coming
from and make sure I get it that's like
the two version of feedback and then you
can turn up the volume as you get
comfortable as you understand the person
and how they react because some people
you can say all the great things in the
world and have one little negative one
they're going to obsess about the
negative one and your next five one-on
ones will be affected by that that other
people there'll be lots of they'll only
hear the positives you said something
you felt was pretty direct and somehow
flies right over their head they miss it
so you got to be attentive to what's
going on in the conversation and say
okay how is this landing and turn it up
over time I find that's a better way
than than the crap sandwich okay bunch
of different questions here these are
all really good topics categories you
know checking in what are our priorities
we got our feedback one we already
talked about we got our career
conversations I'm just going to call out
one that I really personally have gotten
a lot of value on which is the in the
middle for the check-in any sneaky
issues worrying you so what do I mean by
a sneaky issue that's something that's
small maybe in the back of someone's
mind it's kind of picking at them and
picking at them it's not a big deal I
don't need to bring it up yet but it's
it's it's simmering it's simmering and
then it boils over and once it boils
over it's actually a big problem if you
can ask questions that get you to those
earlier simmering levels it's much
easier to address challenges so that's
just one of my personal favorites from
this this big list here um so I told you
tactics these tactics are going to be
dead simple they're going to be so
obvious some of them you probably
already do but if you build in the
habits around them and give them a try
and put the multiples together you're G
to get more out of one-on ones you're
going to move your team forward so the
first tactic topic scorecard all you're
going to do is take a list like that one
I have in here I have a link to it at
the end um you can use that list you can
do your own list but you're going to set
your along arm for five minutes before
your next one-on-one with whoever it is
and you're going to pull up that list of
topics and you're just going to spend a
little bit of time planning out what's a
good topic for me and that person this
week this month five minutes is all I
ask for makes a huge difference in
adding the quality you're about to spend
a half hour or 45 minutes with this
person going through stuff all you have
to do is take five minutes ahead of time
to do a little bit of planning goes a
really long
way so um one last comment on team leads
and team member one-on ones um a lot of
data teams I find are Matrix so what do
I mean by that you have a data person
they're on a team with maybe a bunch of
software developers or another skill set
going on and then they report the data
person reports up through a data chain
if you had like a data management team
and that kind of thing if you have that
situation I just encourage you to spend
a little extra time in that supportive
mode and spend time talking about the
goals of that team if you're embedded
and you have a specialty and you have a
bunch of other people that don't have
that same specialty understanding what
they're trying to achieve and tailoring
your efforts to there is really
important last thing is if you're the
manager on that other team make sure you
have the occasional one-on-one with the
team lead that your person is in again
talk about goals and how it's going help
them head off U troubles if you
can so moving on to the next type of
one-on-one we have you and your boss um
so for you and your boss you're going to
want to spend a little more time here
prepping for it because frankly what
does boss mean right so we're assuming
some level up or even a couple of levels
up the hierarchy basically each level up
is going to add complexity it's going to
add like more stuff that they're
supposed to know about and so you're
going to help them by setting a little
bit more context and being understanding
about where they're coming from I mean
basically right if you The Wider your
scope the more things you don't know and
you know that's part of why managers
often seem clueless and I say that as a
manager who has often seemed clueless
wider scope more likely not to know
things that's just the nature of the
Beast so when you're going into that
you're going to say okay I need to
understand a little bit more about where
my boss is coming from and I'm going to
try and tell her to that like wow they
have a wider scope I want to understand
where they're coming from tell her to
that make it efficient for them to
remember things um and help them through
that um another goal we have is to
really avoid meeting surprises if they
find find out about something that's
gone wrong on your team or something
that wasn't delivered but it's with
meetings with some of their peers or
those kind of things you don't want them
to find out from someone else so one of
your goals is always when you're looking
at your topics if you have something
that they might hear about later try and
give them the heads up that's going to
go a long way to avoiding uh painful
situations and conversations later um
and then my last thought on this goal is
just be explicit about what you're
asking for from them that'll help them
give you the feedback if you're saying
hey this is just to inform you of what
I'm doing or what's going on in the team
or this thing about the project say
informing if it's more like hey I really
want some advice about this I don't know
this or that ask for advice be specific
the last thing is if you need an action
for them call it out ask say hey I need
your action I need your help on this
thing get this funding go to that other
person that kind of thing so again
you're meeting with your boss ask and
categorize those different things um
okay we're on to tactic two um
tactic two again super simple you're
probably doing this maybe you are maybe
you aren't I highly recommend it if
you're not all we're going to do is have
a shared document that's going to be the
history of our uh different one-on ones
that we've had so you're going to just
have a date you're going to have the
topics that you picked out in the
previous five minutes before maybe a
little bit of stuff on there and then
takeaways and action items so just and
then you're going to rotate those down
in the shared list again that's going to
be the context that I mentioned as a
goal help your boss they can kind of
read through those things they can put
stuff in there all stuff like that so I
think not having my notes I'm running a
little behind so apologize for the speed
of the end but I'm going to kind of
power on through here so the third type
so we have two tactics and two types
last one is between you and your peers
in that one you're going to really focus
on the shared space that you have
together a lot of organizations whether
it's at the team level or the bigger
group level a lot gets lost between team
members or between groups there's
essentially gaps that open up and you're
going to use the one-on-one to like
establish what that landscape is hey
what are where do we have dependencies
where could things get disconnected that
kind of thing again you have these gaps
and you're going to use your one-on-one
with peers to fill those in again
between members of a team or across um
into other ones you can almost think of
it as a little like mini retrospective
of like what's going well what's not
going well let's explore this I guess as
a pro tip in this one um offering a
little bit of help can go a really long
way whether you know if that maybe
that's across groups or that kind of
thing um and accepting help if they have
it that is going to build up trust help
fill that Gap and not allow things and
allow waste to kind of fall in those
gaps in
between so our third tactic we're going
to just do and we're going to be
intentional about planning our one-on
ones so what do I mean by that we're
going to just do a little Network graph
we're going to put ourselves in the
center we're the center of the universe
that's wonderful we're going to put
other people that we need from the
organization ation around us that to
help us and for us to help them the most
important relationships you're going to
have and you're just going to look at it
and you're going to put the closeness
for how important they are then you're
going to look at your one-on-one
schedule and say hey does my one-on-one
schedule reflect who I think the most
important relationships to my success
and my group success are and my guess is
if you do that there's a couple that are
missing and the pro tip in this case is
don't just have one-on ones especially
with peers of the ones you like and have
a good time some one-on-one are fun
often it's the one ones that aren't as
fun are the relationships that need work
or where the gaps are going to open up
so don't fall into the Trap of oh that's
the fun one I'll keep doing those and oh
there's this other one and ah it didn't
get rescheduled I'm G to let that go
don't fall into that trap
um so Network graph be intentional and
frankly all things have their Seasons
there may be times where like hey the
last couple one-on ones haven't been
that fruitful make it less frequent let
it drop off the
list okay what we're going for in all of
these things is something that has has
come up a lot for me at posit in
particular which is we're trying to get
people aligned enough and not have gaps
so that they can make a lot of their own
decisions they can stay independent do
what they need to do but they're doing
it pulling in the same direction and
it's sort of interesting because posit
you know again I'm working with the open
source teams amazing teams these are
like some of the most autonomous you
know software Engineers I've worked with
in my long history of doing this so that
having goals that are understood having
trust between team members gets that
much more important so you're enabling
the autonomy so it's really important
again aligned we're going in the same
direction but autonomous we know enough
to make really good decisions and be
independent and get our get our piece of
the work
done so um
yeah in conclusion um I'm just making a
plug for technical management it's been
an awesome career for me it's been
really interesting different challenges
and frankly there's often opportunities
because so many technical people are
afraid of kind of oh I don't want to
fall into the Trap of going into
management it means there's
opportunities there and not just
opportunities for yourself but
opportunities to serve the team um okay
down to my last minute I want to just
indulge my silly Dr Seuss stuff a little
bit more and I have a quick poem that's
hopefully going to remind you about
everything and maybe even cover some of
the things I missed since I haven't had
my speaker notes um in the land of the
office where meetings reside let's talk
about one ones oh they can't be denied
for they're more than just chatter more
than just talk they're the path to
success not a casual walk so listen up
closely for tactics are here to make all
your one-on-one something quite dear
tactic one my friend is a TP tip quite
Divine rotate different topics let
variety shine don't dwell on status oh
no not too long for a mix of discussions
will make your bond strong tactic 2 you
see is a gem quite rare always prepare
notes show that you care keep a shared
running set for both you and for me so
when we look back our progress will see
tactic 3 I yes is the key to the door
draw out relationships you'll find so
much more schedule frequency and length
though so wisely for those are the
moments that matter precisely so there
you have it tactics 1 two and three
apply them with care and then you will
see though they may seem simple don't
let that confound for their impact on
success is truly profound as your one-on
ones flourish like a well- tended tree
together together how great we all be
thank you very
much thank you so much
[Applause]
Andrew